we got a good story here you were
already freaking out when I when I
started reading this one oh man
you wanna all right well hold on hold on
yeah without without scrolling down just
read the title dog owner spends 4.6
million on superbowl advert thanking vet
for saving his pets life there's there's
a subhead it says seven-year-old scout
was given just one month to live before
vets intervened now before we actually
read the story what do you think I think
it's ridiculous that he spent that much
money on on an advert when it's
basically 6 million when that that vet
probably could have used that money
himself for his life like you know what
thanks for saving this here's 4.6
million dollars for for you to use like
what what is the point of this it's like
what is he really trying to do like tell
the world what happened yes is that it
no you just fell for the oldest well a
modern media trick what is a really good
example of what's wrong with the media
the story is not about him thanking vet
for saving his pets life the story is
him launching a fundraiser for the
university I believe of madison's and
veterinarian research they framed it
that way so you would have that reaction
yeah when you see the headline you'd be
like that's so dumb why would he do that
I assure you they're people walking
around right now being like what a dumb
waste of money
it does here's the real story mm-hmm guy
it's it's the mascot unofficial mascot
for a company whether tech his dog's
life was saved and so he decided to
launch a fundraiser for the university
and so we bought an advertisement asking
people to donate to the university
bringing awareness to what they do how
they help animals and how other people
can donate and I assure you they're
gonna make more than 6 million dollars
back mm-hmm so in it my first reaction
was was yeah why don't they just you
know why does he just give them the
money they can use it no awareness could
be more important yeah you're definitely
right read the story now see a dog owner
is so grateful to a veterinary school
for saving his pets life that he is
thanking them with four point six mil
Superbowl advert that's pounds though so
it's sick yeah okay six mil basically in
the summer of 2019 David McNeil was told
but his dog Scout had been diagnosed
with an aggressive cancer in his blood
cell walls or vessel walls the prognosis
was not good and vets told McNeal that
the seven-year-old dog had just one
percent chance of survival and about a
month to live see quote there was there
he was in the middle room was what he
said
there he wasn't in his in this little
room standing in the corner and he's
wagging his tail at me I'm like I'm not
putting that dog down there's just
absolutely no way
Scott was eventually brought to
University of wisconsin-madison where he
immediately underwent chemotherapy and
radiation to target the tumor on his
heart you know it's funny though let me
stop real quick you know my initial
reaction was to this story mm-hmm your
reaction was like that's so dumb I would
do that my reaction was oh I'd totally
do that if I could I would I would
literally be like if someone saved like
bucko if someone like saved him I'd be
like I'm buying you a billboard in Times
Square I'm gonna put you this guy saved
my cat it's not my cat that honestly
it's it's uh it's Emily's cat but for
those who know what uh Tim's octave his
vocal octaves go up like 10 as soon as
he's around this cat oh yeah because you
got it you got to speak in the right
range of the cat cuz I'll tell you this
so when you're when you when you speak
low it's got freaked out he's like
what's it what's that was a noise that's
a low Rumble but let's let's read a
little bit more and see what's going on
with this this year scout huzzah life
got saved let's go out there he is Brad
is Scout he is a nice little Golden
Retriever they say one month later vets
reported that Scouts tumor had shrunk by
approximately 78%
before falling a 90% today the tumor has
almost completely disappeared to thank
the experts at UWM Mick MacNeil decided
to put together a 30-second advert
sponsored by his floorcare company
weather tech titled lucky dog which
tells Scouts story from diagnosis to
recovery
hi I'm scout and I'm a lucky dog a
voiceover on the advert begins and it's
not just because I found a cool stick a
house that's actually kind of cringy
it's that I'm a cancer survivor had a
tumor on my heart and only a 1% chance
of survival the advert we just set to
air during the second quarter of the
Super Bowl on the 2nd of February yes
I'm excited for that by the way it's
gonna be awesome
Super Bowl party cost McNeal 6
million dollars to make okay but to buy
the space shows scout playing on a beach
before walking down the halls of a
veterinary school alongside some of the
real some of the real-life pet health
experts who helped save his life at the
end of the commercial viewers are
encouraged to donate to the cancer
research efforts via Alenka McNeil's
company website their research has the
potential to save millions of pets lives
the voice-over says pets make a
difference in your life you can make a
difference in theirs McNeil said the
statement that he create created the
advert to raise awareness and financial
support for the incredible research and
innovative treatments happening at the
University of Wisconsin School of
Veterinary Medicine he continued we
wanted to use the biggest stage possible
to highlight scout story in these
incredible breakthroughs which are not
just limited to helping dogs and pets
this research will will help advance
cancer treatments for humans as well so
there's the potential to save millions
of lives
of all species yes all right that's way
nicer than than what I originally
exactly picked it in my head it's like
it like what you just said a billboard
would feel like a complete waste to me
right you know and that's what I assumed
when I read that title it's like so what
he's putting a billboard basically I
think thanks for saving my dog but
that's not right I know that's not at
all what it is do you now understand why
I rag on the media so much oh yeah you
knew what they were doing with this
headline definitely and that's messed up
because this is not some selfish stupid
vanity project right this is him saying
I've got a great story the research they
do can help humans to is an excellent
research that's awesome I wanted to
start a fundraiser for them and so they
try and frame it like he's just doing
this vanity thing like you know it's
like it's still cool if someone saved
your dog and you wanted to thank them
but the story is so much bigger than
that yeah yeah exactly
I'll tell you what though let's let's
let's let's we can rag on the media all
day and night but let's talk about
saving dogs lives
I was recently I won't I won't get too
specific on the story but I was recently
dealing with some some pet family scares
mm-hmm and the vet told me he basically
said you know about is about my
brother's dog you know what just give
him some painkillers and it was a very
serious issue I don't give too much
detail because my brother and the dogs
but the attitude he had with us was I
mean if you wanted to spend the money
yeah you can go get him
you know MRI and all that stuff to save
his life and so it basically felt to me
like I'm not trying to mean to the vet
like iris I appreciate him actually
trying to help you know yeah you know my
brother's dog and everything mm-hmm but
the attitude he had was very much like I
don't expect you to want to spend any
money to save this dog's life now yeah
have you heard about how Millennials are
buying like gourmet food for their pets
and stuff yeah yeah you know why they're
doing it no because they're not having
kids so they're their kids are their
dogs yep so now instead of getting like
gruel and like cardboard bits from you
know Walmart yeah they're getting like
this this the fancy you know special
delivery
did we just lose the little monitor cut
out again that someone might when that
happens
Oh actually that's that's maybe why it's
uh it's okay this is really annoying and
everything's spazzing out yep what is
going on I have no idea what's happening
if somehow we're still alive maybe we
are all the monitors just basically cut
out at the same time and I have no idea
oh let's do this all right I guess did
that solve the problem you know what
that's a bummer now let's see if I can
okay I guess we're still alive for those
that are listening one of them on etre
panels just like totally fritzed out and
i think it was mine and that explains
why yours is still there but yeah can I
can i maybe get the story back over to
you and then you can take oh you can
take it over what's uh there we go yeah
all right so now Adam can handle that
kind of the reading stuff so I can't
actually get to it so let's just we'll
send it over to you well no okay sorry
sorry about that guys maybe we can
splice that out when we put the clip up
I don't know what was it oh yeah so
basically the vet is treating you know
it's treating the life of the family pet
as though like nobody would want to
spend this money and I think it's fair
to say a lot of people probably wouldn't
we'll probably couldn't right but there
is this big shift now we're you know
Millennials treat their pets like
members of their family and not just the
dog you know what I mean
yeah well I mean dogs have basically
been we've done that because we
want them there I mean there are our
love slaves basically what like to what
lengths though would you go to like save
your pets life that's an interesting
question too so like you guys can
comment and you know super chats or
whatever and we'll love that's a tough
question you know because it's like I've
I've seen my well when I was living at
my mom she had many dogs and I've seen
one of them attack the other one I've
actually had to like pry the jaws off of
another dog because they were attacking
each other and I couldn't like so what
you're saying is that you trust dogs and
dogs are dangerous I know that can be
but it's it's you know it's it's scary
though because you know then you have an
injury it could be man it really could
be devastating monetarily wise like not
many people can afford what was the
study it's like a $400 swing in their in
their daily like an emergent like a $4
million buddy like nothing caught under
400 bucks everything's gonna be a couple
thousand but it leaves but it's it's
crazy to me like I get it man you're not
gonna you're not gonna you know if you
had to if you had to spend a million
dollars save your kid's life you'd do it
you'd figure it out yeah dog you
probably wouldn't I guess but that
that's like I don't know we had the
money I'd probably go to much greater
lengths to protect you know my dog or my
cat or whatever pet yeah because I care
about them
and I kind of feel like this - it's more
so with dogs cuz I like dogs better than
cats and dogs to me are like everything
humans value in other humans
unconditional love and loyalty mmm-hmm
and obedience it's like I look at dogs
and they're like faithful soldiers who
are like yes sir not all of them you
know but like a good family no they are
to their owner right there they're your
lieutenant man basically I think about
like humans hunting with dogs and like
dogs were like I trust you mm-hmm like
let me know what you need we'll make
this work yeah unconditional loyalty man
you know the story of Hachiko the dog
yeah yeah so for those that don't I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you a couple
stories that I'm gonna totally ruin but
I'm telling anyway Hachiko would go with
this
every day to the train station drop him
off and then come back when when the
presser was returning and wait for his
train to arrive one day there's a lot to
the story to that I'm kind of cutting
out but one day the professor he had a
stroke while he was he was teaching
never came back Hachiko went back to the
train station and waited for him he
never showed up and he never left well
technically he did they tried moving him
but he would always come back and it was
like I think for 10 years he would
always find his way back to the station
and sit there waiting that's that's
that's that's amazing
yeah and so they build a statue for him
mm-hmm now there's like a stand and I
don't know a whole lot about it but I
don't know much about what's going on
Japan but apparently like there's like a
loyalty day inspired by Hachiko I think
it's March 8th I could be wrong and
there was like some big moment where
they someone found a recording that had
hot Chico's bark on it and like they
were able to put the record vinyl record
back together and then like millions of
people tuned in the radio to hear the
bark of this legendary dog that was you
know profoundly loyal ok now I'm gonna
tell you the thing I'm gonna tell you a
brutal story a totally brutal brutal
story and we can wrap up second with
this one I'm gonna get it wrong so the
Welsh take it up with me send me angry
letters for ruining your story but I'm
gonna tell it to the best of my
abilities it's a it's a it's a Welsh
story about it's called Gellert grave
this story's brutal we don't know if
it's true or not but it's a brutal story
so I'll just try and keep it really
simple basically there was this dude in
Wales back in like I don't know 1100
1380 and he had a dog he had a baby and
you know he went out of his little cabin
to go do his like I don't know I don't
know what is what errands were back in
11 1300 or whatever like collecting
sticks or something or hunting rabbits I
have no idea but he goes out for the day
and he comes home and he sees that his
home is like just like totally messed up
just like ransacked and like things are
not cooked knocked over he frantically
tries searching for the crib where his
baby was and he sees that the manger has
been flipped and there's blood
everywhere
and then all of a sudden his dog Gellert
walks up wagging his tail with blood all
over his face and I think I think Prince
Llewyn was the name because I'm probably
ruining your legend Welsh but anyway he
sees his dog covered
blood and everything ruined any and he
says you know he thinks he killed my son
immediately pulls out his sword and
thrusts it into the side of his dog
Gellert who lets out a dying whelp which
wakes up his baby and so then when he
hears the sound of his son crying he
looks over at the flipped over manger
and he moves some of the rubble in the
debris away and flips over the manger
and there's his son safe and sound next
to a dead wolf that Gellert had slain
protecting his son from danger and in
his assumption and panic he killed the
dog who saved his son's life and as
legend tells it he never smiled again I
would really love to do like a little
short flim about that but it's basically
there's like this place in Wales I think
I think it's in Wales you know be really
funny if it's not Welsh and I'm like the
Welsh feel like to him it's not our
legend no it is oh you give me a thumbs
up okay
but dude brutal story sons brutal Wow
some say it's not real some say that
it's a it's a story just to tell you not
to make assumptions and to think things
through without panicking others believe
the story is true but I think they like
there's like a rock called Keller's
grave or something a tree or something
and the dogs both be buried there but
like I read somewhere that like they did
like an ultrasound or something and
there's nothing there so it's like not a
true story I got to be honest I hope
it's not a true story yeah it's brutal
that'd be cool you know I think that I
think it would be actually a really
great short film on a couple of minutes
long because it does tell a really
important lesson about not making
assumptions about you know anything
it'll be calm and it's one or the
reasons I like it it's also just because
it's like man could you imagine the pain
a person would feel realizing that did
that to like the I don't care if it's an
animal a person who just saved the life
of your child and you thought they were
the bad person and you you you hurt them
yeah killed them and then realized they
were the ones who man yeah that's rough
i dude that's one of the reasons I was
I've been talking about friends about
like can we do like a short film like
this because like capturing the emotion
yeah of someone realizing what they had
done it would be a pain worse than
witnessing the death of like when your
dog dies it hurts when your friend dies
it hurts but knowing you did it would be
like I gotta tell you man if hell is
real it's probably that feeling yeah
for eternity that's scary stuff
you